all right uh so today's topic then any
four offensive players
the top four
look i
how can i not go tom brady mike evans
chris godwin and rob gronkowski i mean i
wanted to use a running back but they
don't have one that really stands out
they got ronald jones they got leonard
fournette i gotta go brady evans godwin
gronk i got two i got two they're the
champions
i i that's who i would have picked but
i'll take kansas city i'll take my homes
kelsey
uh tyreek hill and i'll take machole
hardman over
uh anybody else including clyde edwards
hilaire and i'll just throw the ball 65
times a game
you know isn't it funny though as we try
to do this
it is for most of them
like the beatles like three guys with
talent and then ringo starr like who's
the fourth guy like for some of them
i'm sorry ringo uh the let's offend the
lone survive oh no paul mccartney is
alive too unless he isn't all right
let's offend both of them
[Laughter]
well i mean if you play the records
backward they're sending you messages he
barely buried paul
all right
let me go with uh the browns is the
browns
because they got baker mayfield they got
obj if he's healthy they got jarvis
landry they got nick chubb and and there
is no ringo starr among that group so uh
hey it's we got to get our brains around
the idea that the browns are no longer
the browns and they deserve to be
included in lists like this peter
okay i am going my next one i'm gonna
pick the atlanta falcons and mike i'll
tell you this right now i'm picking the
atlanta falcons even if they trade julio
jones
and i think there's a 60 40 chance that
before july 25th they trade julio jones
we'll see
but i'm going to keep julio jones on
there and go julio jones calvin ridley
kyle pitts and matt ryan in my opinion
that quartet would make some beautiful
music together
i am going to take a leap of faith here
and i agree with you on the falcons i'm
going to take a leap of faith that joe
burrows going to be ready to go week one
because hey we got to stay in the afc
north we're going to stay in ohio who
would have ever dreamed that i'd peg
both of the ohio teams as having
dangerous quartets but you got joe
burrow
you got joe mixon you got jamar chase
and then you go ahead and put tyler boyd
on there you can put t higgins in too oh
yeah let's go five deep but yeah if
chase is as good as they think he's
gonna be and we know mixon who's been
running behind not much of an offensive
line is capable of being very good bro
was great last year until he got injured
i think the bengals again changing
perceptions in this new nfl where the
ohio football teams not only are
relevant but they have great offenses so
give me those four
i got an upset special for my next one
mike and that's the los angeles rams
matthew stafford and
a guy who if he's healthy for 17 games i
think is going to gain 1300 yards and
that's cam acres i think he's going to
be one of the best backs in the league
this year
and then at wide receiver i'll take
cooper cup and robert woods although to
me
van jefferson this year who is going to
play a lot has a very good chance of
catching 60 or more balls with a really
good yards per catch average so i'll
take the rams for my next one
oh and they have desean jackson and they
have 2-2 atwell amazing what that
offense can be and those pieces that
sean mcvay i just don't count on desean
jackson you know we're
at the point where it's almost like
whatever he gives you is a bonus
and and that's the key if he just shows
up for a game or two and gives you 150
yards and a couple of touchdowns that
may be the difference between winning
the division and not all right let's do
a fourth round i i'll go with the
vikings here because even though you
know there's questions about how good
the defense is and the offense sputters
at times between kirk cousins dalvin
cook justin jefferson and adam thielen
that is a very potent quartet
they just need to put it all together
this year and they need the hope the
offensive line can allow those four to
get the most out of their abilities
peter
look i it to me it's easy how could how
could eight teams be picked where you're
looking for a great quartet
and we don't choose in the first seven
the buffalo bills you know with josh
allen you know with stefan diggs cole
beasley
and look
i'll take for my next guy a guy who i
think is going to have a breakout year
and that's devin singletary um i i think
he has sort of been
i don't want to say shocked into
thinking that okay you just got to get
better and you got to get better at
everything
and i think he will this year i think
he's going to be a really good back for
them this year
you know i had the bills started because
you got to have josh allen you got to
have stefan diggs
but it's one thing to struggle with the
fourth one i struggled with three and
four and if you got to struggle with
three i thought you you can't get on the
list i didn't struggle with cole beasley
i think i mean cole beasley was my was
my slot
guy on my uh
on my all pro team last year i thought
you were the one last year so you were i
was the one
and i admit it and i will defend it
until i'm blue in the face or whatever
red in the face
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports